what's the deal with entity component
systems and why do game engines
typically have them
and maybe i'll just give you some some
quick tips on this because you know what
this is
game
i don't remember what i call this game
engine quick tip
i'm aiming for five minutes so
all right ecs what's the deal right how
does it work
give me the short quick version so i can
yeah i can move on that that's what you
want okay i hear you that's what i was
looking for what's well it's actually
way way simpler than i thought i've read
a lot i've researched a lot i've
practiced and implementation
and i keep learning new things as i go
yeah okay so here's how i like to think
of it and i think it makes it simple an
entity is your
game object it's just something in a
scene so typically you have like
when you're thinking of a game you have
a scene and if you want every entity to
have its own unique
place or id or whatever
that's your entity okay so what's the
component in the system
the component in the system
is well you can think of it as just one
thing just think of it as a component
the components typically have systems in
them for like their update
and whatever
special stuff you want to attach to it
systems are basically what's going to
happen on the fly so don't even worry
about that it's usually just like
put in with the component or at least
that's probably how i'm going to do it
in my component it's just any aspect of
some
thing it could be a position
usually you want everything to have
a
transformation
but you might also want to have other
special stuff like you might have
well camera lights
uh
my mesh info is going to be renderable
in my case
i'm going to have a sky box
that i'm still trying to figure out how
to do because i think i'm going to
attach it to the camera
but i'm not exactly sure how it's going
to work with the entity component system
so
my example over here is not the greatest
let me show you a website so i think
this makes it a lot more simple and this
is from david coulson
uh this isn't the only place i've
researched i've looked at a lot of
different things but this one helped me
understand one thing that's very
critical
uh so your entity ids here this little
column right
the
bit mask
of components
is just like a big grid so every entity
either has it or does not have it
and this
uh bit mask is just like a flag of it
has it or it doesn't have it and that
way
it can go to where it needs to go to
update all those
all right
so this is obviously a lot more
confusing than just like wrapping all
the functionality up in one class so why
would you do it well the reason is it's
all about cpu cache basically because
when you make giant game objects
and you start creating a bunch of them
they end up really fragmented in memory
and you end up reusing a lot of stuff
but it's all fragmented so when you're
iterating through it to do your update
or whatever it is your cpu cache is just
like
blah it's loading in stuff that it
doesn't necessarily need all the time
because it loads and stuff that's next
to whatever you're using automatically
so typically what that means is you want
the data you're operating on to be right
next to each other so that when it's
loaded into your cpu cache
it's uh ready to go for the next part
and it doesn't have to
miss it's what they call it a cache miss
hopefully that makes sense it probably
will if you're a programmer
and uh have seen this before
with this what you end up doing is you
create these large arrays of all the
components you're using
and they're attached to entity ids
and so when you go through your entity
ids
or through your components
you can do it either way you can go
through your components and update all
of them
and then then they end up affecting
the entity
and when you're doing that
you can basically update all the
components
of a similar type at once and it's very
cash efficient you basically end up with
pointers two arrays all over the place
which is a lot cheaper than having a
bunch of giant objects that are just
kind of scattered and all over the place
at least you have
nice concise arrays of help go do work
here go to work here and that's
essentially the point and uh
i think that summarizes it
there's obviously a lot more to it but
that's the super quick version and uh
yeah see in the next one
oh and one more thing before i go
you don't need to do this you don't need
an entity component system
unless you're having problems with cash
misses if you're just making a little
game or something and it's going fine
and you're not having performance
problems there's no reason to start
worrying about ecs it's the home the
whole thing with ets is
it's it's a way to solve a problem as
with everything
in this field the problem is cpu cache
misses with large game objects
ecs is basically the best solution and
to be honest when you think about it
it's not necessarily all that original
it's basically just a hash map of saying
hey if you have this quality
go here
so
it's a very common solution to these
sort of problems you see it with a lot
of other things too now rambling on i
got to end this for real uh you see it
with things like the indexing in in
meshes like you know how you have a
triangle face
uh if you're using an element buffer or
an index buffer it's kind of the same
thing you see that all over in
programming algorithmically gives you
faster
results
for those scenarios
god that was a that was a real bs
sentence you can you can call me out on
that